speaking of evidence of things uh that
were claimed
what do you think about the hunter Biden
laptop or as you tweeted the laptop from
Hell the laptop from Hell TM right uh to
what degree was this uh laptop story
important
um to what degree was it not
at this point
I have said many times
if there is any reason to believe that
Hunter Biden Joe Biden Naomi Biden Jill
Biden Hillary Obama Doug M if there's
any evidence any of them committed a
crime they should be investigated
they should be charged
and they should be tried period
the hunter Biden laptop thing has been
floating around for so long
and we still have zero actual
uh pieces of evidence of any crime
particularly involving Joe Biden there's
the claim from some that references to
the big guy are about Joe Biden getting
10 for some illicit it's been years
they've been saying this they've not
been able to bring forward any evidence
on it so my assessment of the hunter
Biden laptop is
it seems to mostly be a story about nude
images released without someone's
consent which is illegal in Most states
and violates Twitter's own policies
that's the main story to me beyond that
I don't know how many people have a copy
of this hard drive at this point Rudy
had it Tucker do you remember when
Tucker this is this is unbelievable
Tucker said that he mailed himself
a copy a USB stick yeah and it got lost
in the mail you you have the motherload
proving the criminality of Joe and
Hunter Biden and I don't you just
dropped it off with a stamp and it got
lost in the mail you don't have a backup
copy you don't so I'm ready for the
evidence to come forward Hunter Biden
has nothing to do with Joe Biden's
Administration but as a person who
if he committed a crime charge them
investigate him whatever but it's it's
getting it's almost getting satirical
the degree to which they're talking
about the hunter Biden laptop uh what do
you think about the the social media
aspect of this that that story got
censored
and what do you think about censorship
in General on social media that that
story during an important time in the
electoral process got censored so I uh
as a matter of principle
I think we have to Define what we mean
by censorship but I'm against censorship
short of illegal content I guess is the
way I would put it I do respect the
company's right to have terms of service
and to enforce them as long as they're
not illegal if Twitter were to say we
don't publish content from Jewish people
okay now we've got a problem on our
hands but
um what what is dubious to me
is the claim that had people been able
to see Hunter Biden's genitals they
would have voted for Trump which I know
it's like David you're you're making
light of and but at the end of the day
what exactly is the claim that if you
had known more about Hunter Biden I
guess allegedly hiring prostitutes and
and having a drug problem and seeing
pictures you wouldn't have voted for Joe
Biden I mean I know me as a voter I
don't feel that way
I think uh it's less about the content
of the story and about the actions of uh
a social media company
to control what you're seeing what you
don't see so you can imagine a social
media company like Facebook and Twitter
making the same kind of decision about
our more impactful story then uh a few
dick pics on a laptop well I think if
that happened then my view might be
different right but I do my general view
though on the hunter Biden story is
had the Articles not contained those
images that were illegal in many states
and violated Twitter's policies I would
say publish it absolutely I don't think
it would have had an impact but I would
be in favor of it being of the links
being allowed a hundred percent
okay uh you mentioned Tucker what do you
think about talking getting fired from
Fox
um you're a media person that works
independently yes
was a media person